tel aviv centre économique de l'état
d'israël une ville a priori paisible où
les menaces semblent lointaines pourtant
il arrive parfois que des sirènes
résonnent pour alerter sur l'arrivée de
roquettes sur la ville
même si ces alertes ont été relativement
rares ces derniers mois de plus en plus
d'immeubles sont désormais équipés d'une
pièce un peu spécial mon petit on
appelle le mit clac c'est à dire la
chambre forte où on va se réfugier si il
ya une alerte à la bombe
le mic lattes une salle bunkeriser que
nous présente pierre ray of réalisateur
engagé ce qu'il n'ya pas grand chose il
ya la possibilité quand même vous avez
des échelles qui permettent d'aller dans
les étages à l'autre et de vous enfuir
si jamais il y avait un gros problème
une otan feu ascenseurs sont en panne et
ses voeux l'avons ne s'en est pas servi
depuis quelques années donc heureusement
il ya juste deux chaises pour pouvoir
s'asseoir attend que ça passe
évidemment tous à les berner comme la
porte un peu l'épaisseur des murs
épaisseur on peut vraiment se prendre
des roquettes dans la figure bien comme
il faut et il se passera rien ici on est
la brouille selon pierre ray of les
israéliens suivent assidûment
l'actualité car ils se savent à la merci
des conséquences d'un conflit qui dure
depuis des dizaines d'années les
istréens leurs habitudes depuis que le
pays est né et même avant la naissance
du pays de combattre des attentats
terroristes et de vivre de vivre au
quotidien
comme si demain tout pouvait arriver on
a quand même cette possibilité qu'à tout
moment dans la rue dans une que
quelqu'un vienne se faire sauter et ça
c'est derrière derrière les esprits en
permanence les israéliens ont vraiment
envie de vivre normalement
la normalité et la paix sont vraiment
les deux mots qui sont les plus
dominants de la société israélienne
selon le service de sécurité intérieure
israélien
560 attaque terroriste de grande ampleur
ont été déjouées en 2019 et pour se
protéger encore davantage contre les
roquettes qui atteignent israël le
gouvernement de l'état hébreu à
débloquer deux milliards de shekels
supplémentaires soit environ
520 millions d'euros on est à ramallah
en cisjordanie ville située à quelques
kilomètres seulement de la frontière
très surveillé par l'armée israélienne
on est parti à la rencontre d'habitants
palestiniens pour comprendre comment ils
vivent cette proximité avec une arme et
qu'il juge parfois trop envahissante
oui nous sommes effrayés par
l'occupation en elle-même on peut vous
arrêter à n'importe quel moment sans
aucune raison on dirait qu'ils veulent
prouver qu'ils existent dans ce café
nous rencontrons manel étudiante en
médecine elle aussi dit redouter les
incursions de l'armée israélienne
les israéliens toutes les nuits ils
viennent ici et personne ne sort
personne ne se sent en sécurité
les gens ont peur de mon point de vue le
futur ne sera pas bon j'ai deux mauvais
pressentiment pour le moment ce n'est
pas trop dangereux mais dans le futur ça
sera pire
le pessimisme est de rigueur côté
palestinien fatigué par des années de
conflits et les récentes annonces de
donald trump n'ont fait qu'accentuer ce
sentiment
[Musique]